valérie benaïm voulait revenir sur une
petite souris chaude oui tout à fait
parce que vous avez passé un bon
week-end vous est très bon et qui s'est
bien passé franchement très très bon le
foot vous aimez bien j'adore vous
connaissez marquinho marquinhos
marquinhos exa écran une double
actualité
il est de nouveau papa pas exactement et
puis là c'est une marque de vêtements
exactement et j'adore ce joueur c'est il
a la classe et hier soir j'ai eu la
chance qui m'invite au lancement de sa
marque et avait du très grand champion
je l'aimé énormément marque innocent
voilà c'est un mec que j'adore c'est un
grand champion il ya eu ce qui se
raconte pas et vous avez vous avez des
débats même si j'ai des petites images
il ya plein plein plein de grands
champions qui appuient cette personne
pourquoi savez vous voyez la partie
[Applaudissements]
mais vous êtes football alors je crains
pas pendant le bal je tiens pas bonne le
ballon chez lloyds [ __ ] vous portez là
il faut pas le dire mais voilà et
j'adore ce joueur ou la marque ineos y
avait m ma paye avait neymar et je
voudrais dire un truc sur neymar voilà
neymar j'entends plein de choses sur lui
sachez que c'est un mec qui est un amour
de galles il a fait 50 photos il refuse
jamais les photos c'est une bombe
il est toujours très sympathique et
c'est les récents domec et je l'aimais
énormément voilà je voulais dire on
entend beaucoup de choses sur lui mais
sachez le c'est un bon gars voilà je
voulais dire
mais voilà après voilà après quand il
est dans un match forcément